[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers in
allen einen guten Samstagabend der nicht
nur für Iranerinnen und Iraner rund um
den Globus ein besonderer ist der nicht
nur die Macht eines gnadenlosen
Sicherheitsapparats zeigt sondern auch
dessen Angst vor den eigenen Bürgern
heute ist es genau ein Jahr her dass die
junge Kurde in massa Amini in der Gewalt
der Sittenpolizei in Irans Hauptstadt
Teheran starb es ist genau ein Jahr her
seid ihr tot die schwersten Proteste
seit Jahrzehnten auslöste gegen das
Regime im Iran überall auf der Welt
erinnern sie heute daran mit Mahnwachen
und protestmärchen Jörg Brase ist live
in Teheran Jörg auch in Tehran selbst
ja also was wir hier gehört haben dass
waren so einzelne hub-konzerte so wie
sie während der Proteste ja jeden Abend
gegeben hat wir haben auch einzelne Rufe
von den Dächern gehört Parolen gegen
Religionsführer Ali Hammer näher beim
Grunde war es dann doch den ganzen Tag
über hier relativ ruhig was sicherlich
mit der massiven Sicherheit äh
präsentiert zu tun hatte wir haben
tausende von Polizei und anti
terroreinheiten gesehen die hier in der
Stadt verteilt waren das war wirklich
furchteinflößend und hat dann sicherlich
auch dazu geführt dass es hier heute
ruhig geblieben ist wir sprechen gleich
noch weiter gucken jetzt aber erstmal
auf das was seit dem 16 September
letzten Jahres in Iran geschah und wie
es bis heute wirkt
Ali jeffer Hahn schuftete in dem kleinen
Laden für Handwerker Bedarf hinterheran
Tag für Tag um die Ausbildung seiner
beiden Töchter zu finanzieren wir Iraner
leben wie in einem Strudel der uns immer
weiter nach unten zieht sagt er aber
seit vor einem Jahr Masse Amini starb
sei einiges in Bewegung gekommen
dieses ehrenhaften Mädchens war einer
der Gründe dafür dass das iranische Volk
begonnen hat sich aus diesem Strudel zu
befreien
ihr Tod vor einem Jahr war der Tropfen
der das fast zum überlaufen brachte
Master armini wurde zum Symbol der
Proteste gegen die Kopftuchpflicht gegen
hohe Preise gegen das müller-regie das
schlug den Volkszorn brutal nieder es
gab viele Opfer 10 tausende wurden
verhaftet Todesurteile verhängt sieben
davon bislang vollstreckt die
Abschreckung wirkte die Proteste ließen
nach doch viele Frauen leisten bis heute
zivilen Widerstand und tragen kein
Kopftuch mehr
dass ich heute meinen Kopftuch
unbehelligt auf den Schultern tragen
kann sagt diese Frau nach über 40 Jahren
das ist ein großer Fortschritt ob wir
Kopftuch tragen müssen oder nicht ist
mir gar nicht so wichtig meint diese
junge Frau es gibt viele andere Dinge in
unserer Gesellschaft die Frauen unter
Druck setzen und uns Probleme machen und
gegen die wir uns wehren müssen
doch solcher Widerstand sollte gerade
heute verhindert werden Masse aminis
Vater wurde von den Behörden unter Druck
gesetzt in der Heimatstadt zerques keine
Trauer Zeremonie abzuhalten zahlreiche
Regimekritiker wurden bereits im Vorfeld
verhaftet die Zahl der Sicherheitskräfte
in den Straßen massiv erhöht
sind alles Zeichen der Schwäche nicht
der Stärke würde sich das Regime stark
fühlen würde es sich nicht dauernd
verteidigen wer meint sich verteidigen
zu müssen macht sich große Sorgen
um die eigene Macht und vielleicht auch
dass es friedlichen und freundlichen
Menschen wie Alija Varan irgendwann zu
viel wird Ihr Geschäft laufen noch sagt
er anderen aber ginge es schlecht da
Holler Tee die Mehrheit der anderen
Geschäfte steht halb vor der Pleite
unser Land befindet sich in einer Krise
unsere Nation und unser Volk leiden
bis zum Abend blieb es weitgehend ruhig
hinterher ran doch Unzufriedenheit und
Forderungen nach Veränderung werden
bleiben auch über diesen Tag hinaus
ja das Land in der Krise über gerade
gehört haben die Molas immer noch an der
Macht Jörg was hat sich dennoch im Iran
verändert was hat ihre Form und
Protestbewegung erreicht
also viele Frauen mit denen wir hier in
den vergangenen Tagen gesprochen haben
die haben uns gesagt dass sie doch ein
größeres Selbstbewusstsein haben wenn es
darum geht ihre eigenen Rechte
einzufordern sie haben gesagt wir lassen
uns jetzt nicht mehr alles gefallen wir
wollen uns wehren und wir werden dabei
auch zunehmend unterstützt von den
Männern im iranischen Parlament da gibt
es Debatten darüber ob man doch
Zugeständnisse machen soll ob es
Reformen geben soll noch hat da die
Mehrheit der religiös konservativen
Hardliner aber das sagen auch wenn es um
eine mögliche Verschärfung der Kopftuch
Gesetze geht aber da hat uns eine
Politik Professor mit dem wir gesprochen
haben der hat gefragt wie viele Frauen
wollen sie dann letzten Endes festnehmen
und ins Gefängnis stecken das heißt
viele bezweifeln dass diese Gesetze dann
auch tatsächlich umgesetzt werden und
viele rechnen in der Mitte ist es dann
doch Reformen gibt auch weil das Regime
ein Interesse am eigenen macht er halt
hat und weil der Graben zwischen der
politischen Führung und der großen mehr
hat der Bevölkerung im Laufe des
vergangen en Jahres sicher noch ein
großes Stück tiefer geworden ist ja
herzlichen Dank für diese Zwischenbilanz
sondern einem besonderen Tag für Iran
live aus Terran
der russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine
und speziell auch deren
verteidigungsschläge gegen Russland das
ist seit langem auch ein Krieg der
Drohnen dieser meist kleinen unbemannten
aber sehr effektiven Fluggeräte während
Russlands Armee sich aus iranischer
Produktion bedient tüfteln sie in der
Ukraine an einer ganzen Reihe eigener
Entwicklungen über 20 neue Typen
ukrainischer Drohnen sollen angeblich im
Einsatz sein unserem Reporter Henna
Hebestreit ist etwas Bemerkenswertes
gelungen er konnte junge Ukrainer
Treffen in ihrer Werkstatt die sagen sie
arbeiten dort am Krieg der Zukunft
die Bilder des russischen Militärs
zeigen eine Kamikaze Drohne im Ziel
Anflug die angeblich ukrainische
Stellungen zerstört
dieser Krieg ist längst schon ein Krieg
der Drohnen auch ukrainische Truppen
entwickeln ihre ganz eigenen unbemannten
Flugkörper weil küre heißt dieses Gerät
aus Styropor zur Erkundung des
Schlachtfelds
es geht darum Leben zu retten das ist
das wertvollste daher haben die Drohnen
die Situation vehement verändert und
werden das auch noch weiter tun
Walküre wird zur Aufklärung eingesetzt
sie soll russische Geschütze finden
bevor die ihr Feuer eröffnen können
allerdings hat China die Lieferung
wichtiger Bauteile inzwischen nahezu
eingestellt
wir haben das schon kommen sehen und
beschlossen alle wichtigen und
kritischen Bauteile selbst herzustellen
es ist ein Rüstungswettlauf gegen
Russlands drohnenbauer den sie in gut
versteckten Werkstätten bei Kiew führen
hier entwickeln sie auch Langstrecken
Drohnen
es wäre die Batterie umso größer muss
die Drohne sein nur dieser Grenzwert
schränkt uns hinsichtlich der taktischen
Reichweite ein
es ist eine harte technische Nuss die
die Ukraine mit eigenen Mitteln nur mit
großem Aufwand knacken können doch
halten sie symbolische Attacken auf weit
entfernte Ziele auch gar nicht für
kriegsen entscheidend
fliegen so ein Gerät zu bauen ist keine
Raketenwissenschaft
die Zerstörung eines Gebäudes ist
wirtschaftlich weniger sinnvoll als die
Vernichtung eines Panzers oder eines
gegnerischen artilleriesystems für
mehrere Millionen Dollar
in diesem Krieg geht es beiden Seiten
darum mit einem minimum-material dem
Gegner maximalen Schaden zuzufügen
Drohnen können kriegsentscheidend sein
ich denke dass ich die Methoden der
Kriegsführung nach dem Ende dieses
Konfliktes ändern werden jeder
analysiert bereits was passiert und die
Taktiken beim Einsatz unbemannter
Luftfahrzeuge oder Drohnen im Wasser
werden sich stark ändern
nur der Kampf gegen die Drohnen wirkt
heute noch wie der Krieg von gestern
[Musik]
damit zu uns nach Deutschland wo viele
es schleppend geht und manches jetzt
ganz schnell seit dieser Woche liegen
bereits die ersten Röhren der
anbindungspipeline für das neue
flüssig-erdgasterminal auf Rügen im
Wasser und zwar direkt vor dem Strand
von Lubmin Bundeskanzler und
Wirtschaftsminister in Berlin machen
Druck und Tempo Stichwort
Versorgungssicherheit vor Ort dagegen
sind längst nicht alle überzeugt Bernd
Mosebach berichtet
eine halbe Seemeile vor der Küste vor
Pommerns liegt sie die castoro 10 kein
unbekanntes Revier für den Rohrleger an
Nordstemmen 1 und 2 hat er mitgebaut
jetzt also der dritte Versuch hier Gas
an Land zu bringen nachdem die anderen
pipelins gesprengt worden die Rohre
werden in einen Tunnel eingeführt und
bei dominen mit einem mächtigen
Stahlseil an Land gezogen ab Anfang
nächsten Jahres soll das Gas von hier
aus ins europäische Netz eingespeist
werden
Endpunkt der 50 Kilometer langen
Pipeline der Hafen Mukran auf Rügen
Tanke aus aller Welt sollen hier das
verflüssigte Erdgas anlanden der Hafen
der zu 90% der Gemeinde Sassnitz gehört
verspricht sich gute Geschäfte schauen
Sie man kann hier nicht nur alleine
fahren Tourismus existieren ja ich bin
ja gebürtiger bin selbst in der
Fischerei groß geworden bisher gibt es
nicht mehr es gibt hier nur noch
Tourismus und ich saß jetzt mal ganz
erlaubt oder auch provokativ es kann
nicht jeder Koch und Kellner hier auf
Rügen werden
Deutschlands größte Insel lebt vom
Tourismus fünfeinhalb Millionen
Übernachtungen im letzten Jahr der
Widerstand gegen das Projekt ist heftig
organisiert vor allem von der Gemeinde
Binz neue Arbeitsplätze durch LNG für
den Bürgermeister kein Argument wenn
zwei Ingenieure sein und drei
Hausmeister und lassen es auch 20 sein
das ist doch kein Grund um um sowas hier
so eine Industrialisierung der Insel
vorzunehmen dann müssten 10.000
Arbeitsplätze entstehen denn wir setzen
tausende Arbeitsplätze ins Spiel denn
wir gehen ja davon aus dass wir ein
Rückgang eventuell von einem Fünftel der
touristischen Kapazität haben die Winzer
hatten gegen das Projekt geklagt
fürchten Schäden für Tourismus und
Umwelt und halten die Finanzierung für
unseriös die Klage wurde weitgehend
abgeschmettert sind sie seriös ja das
sind wir und das wurde ja mehrfach jetzt
auch intensiv geprüft einerseits durch
das Land im Rahmen der Genehmigung
andererseits durch den Bund durch das
Gericht und auch durch die
Staatsanwaltschaft das war eine
beispiellose lügenkampagne die
Bundesregierung hält das Projekt weiter
für alternativlos die einen sagen wir
brauchen ist nicht weil wir keine
Notlage an Gas mehr befürchten müssen
das halte ich für falsch auch für
fahrlässig das will ich sagen und die
anderen sagen wir brauchen es nicht hier
das verstehe ich aber so funktioniert
Deutschland nicht wir müssen irgendwo
Infrastrukturen bauen das Hotel am Meer
in Binz vor 30 Jahren gebaut von
Wolfgang Schäfer demnächst will er den
Familienbetrieb an seine Tochter
weitergeben und wir spielen hier mit
unserer Existenz das geht ja hier nicht
um ein kleines Bauvorhaben haben Sie
denn noch Hoffnung dass das Projekt noch
verhindert werden kann
ich bin nach wie vor optimistisch weil
ich von dem Projekt überhaupt nicht
überzeugt bin auch wenn einige
Genehmigungen noch ausstehen und die
Gemeinde Binz gerade eine weitere Klage
vorbereitet die ersten anderthalb
Kilometer Rohre sind verlegt die castore
10 schafft täglich neue Fakten
jetzt hier bei uns weitere wichtige
Nachrichten im Überblick den hast du
Hanna
ja zuerst auf die angespannte Lage auf
Lampedusa
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
will die Mittelmeerinsel morgen
gemeinsam mit der italienischen
Ministerpräsidentin Meloni besuchen
diese hatte sich mit einem Hilferuf an
die EU gewandt eloni fordert eine
gemeinsame marine-mission um
migrantenbote auf dem Mittelmeer zu
stoppen seit Wochenbeginn sind tausende
Bootsflüchtlinge auf Lampedusa
angekommen die Insel rief daraufhin den
Notstand aus
[Musik]
in Libyen wächst nach den schweren
Überschwemmungen die Sorge vor der
Ausbreitung von Krankheiten wie Cholera
Behörden und Hilfsorganisationen warten
davor verschmutztes Wasser zu trinken
doch immer fehlt es in vielen Teilen des
katastrophengebiets an medizinischer
Versorgung die WHO erklärte heute das
mittlerweile 4000 Todesopfer
identifiziert werden konnten
erneut ist es bei einer Eritrea
Veranstaltung zu schweren
Ausschreitungen gekommen dieses Mal in
Stuttgart bist du 200 Gegner der
eritreischen Regierung griffen
Eintreffen von Sympathisanten an auch
die Polizei wurde mit Steinen und
Holzlatten attackiert 24 Beamte sein
verletzt worden zwei davon schwer und
170 Personen wurden laut Polizei
festgesetzt im Juli hatte es in Gießen
beim Eritrea Festival ebenfalls
Ausschreitungen gegeben
in München hat heute Mittag das 188
Oktoberfest begonnen pünktlich um 12 Uhr
wurde das erste Fass Bier angestochen 2
[Applaus]
Millionen Besucher auf der Wiesen das
größte Volksfest der Welt
dauert bis zum 3 Oktober das Bier ist
auch dieses Jahr wieder teurer geworden
mit bis zu 14,90€
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die
lauten 19 30 32 36 41 46 Superzahl 2
alle Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr fehlt
noch der Blick auf die Wetteraussichten
morgen kann es im Nordwesten gewittrige
shower geben sonst bleibt es bei viel
Sonne meist nur und meist nur dünnen
Wolken trocken die Temperatur steigt auf
Werte von 22 bis 31 Grad am Montag und
Dienstag gibt es verbreitet shower und
teils kräftige Gewitter am Mittwoch
beruhigt sich das Wetter wieder am
Montag bis 29 danach maximal 25 Grad
und damit von uns allen hier im heute
schon mal Team danke für heute gerne bis
morgen und die nächsten Nachrichten
gibt's hier gegen
einen angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]